these skies are finally blue in my UK
tropical style garden and the daytime
and even nighttime temperatures are
staying nice and warm
all of those hearty resilient plants
that Shrugged off the harsh weather
conditions of winter are thriving in
these conditions my euphorbia cross
pasteri is in full bloom and the Ants
are absolutely loving its sweet nectar
my papaya is in full flour and the Hardy
bananas are reaching for the skies
however there is a problem in Paradise I
encounter this stress-inducing problem
at the same time every single year my
garden is surrounded by boundary walls
and Boundary fences limiting the amount
of space that I've got available to grow
plants in and I'm sure this isn't
something that I suffer alone
so many of us are restricted in our
growing space and as spring turns into
summer we can really feel those
limitations with everything growing away
so how do I overcome these space
limitations when growing a tropical
style Garden here in the UK now small
gardens don't mean you have to limit
yourself as much as you might think over
the years I found a number of ways to
increase the amount of plants that I can
grow in a limited space and I'm going to
share some of those tricks with you now
so for the first trick we're going to
turn to rain forests for inspiration
rainforests grow in layers and by
planting our garden in layers we're
going to be able to utilize everything
that we can learn from a rainforest
plants don't all grow at the same height
in the same conditions they've evolved
to thrive in different niches and by
understanding that we can really
maximize the space that we've got to
grow plants in our Gardens
so let's break these layers down we're
going to look at ground cover plants sub
shrubs shrubs and then trees just like
you'd get in a rainforest
so
ground cover plants plants like Hardy
and patience or this Saxy Fraga
stolonifera which has proven Hardy in my
UK Garden a sarum europeais and so many
more provide good ground cover for what
you might think a difficult growing
conditions they stay small and compact
so you can squeeze them underneath
larger plants
then we're going to move up a layer to
sub shrub plants now in this group I
would put things like Ferns and
herbaceous perennials anything that's
going to grow and fill that void between
the ground cover plants and the bottom
of your larger shrubs so in this group
in a tropical style Garden I would
include things like persicaria
collocages and ferns
many of these sub shrub plants have
adapted to tolerate partial shade so
plants like colic ages and ferns will
thrive in these conditions and you will
have a healthy second layer
let's move up another layer to find more
planting opportunities we're going to
look at shrubs now shrubs are usually
Woody plants that are multi-branched in
a tropical style Garden we're looking at
things like fatiers and sambucus
there is so many plants that you can
choose from but these plants will fill
the gap between your herbaceous exotic
perennials and the canopy of the trees
and that brings us to our next layer the
canopy of trees now trees will climb for
the skies and you can find trees to suit
Gardens of all sizes many trees tolerate
pruning really well so if you stay on
top of your job list you can keep those
trees the perfect size for your garden
no matter what size it is in my garden I
grow the loquat tree I've got a mountain
papaya and this beautiful Golden Leaves
Catalpa big non Theodis the common name
is the golden Indian bean tree and I
speak so much about this Roost tree that
forms the central canopy they are really
easy to grow and really tough just watch
out for root suckers this one is
actually restricted by an old pond liner
see how many planting opportunities
we've got just by breaking down the
available space into a number of layers
we have ground cover plants sub shrubs
shrubs and trees and there are thousands
of plants to choose from no matter what
style of garden you're growing I
personally love tropical Style Plants as
you can see my next trick to maximize
the amount of plants you can grow in a
limited space is to use something that
can break free from the restrictions of
layers we're going to plant climbers
climbers will grow up through the layers
and you don't need a wide open space
because they will go vertical up
whatever support you give them so things
like clematis or Jasmine make fantastic
climbing plants and Jasmine will
fragrance your garden when it's in full
bloom ours smells fantastic in the
height of Summer
and again there are a wide array of
Evergreen climbers that you can use so
that when the rest of the garden might
look a bit tired in Winter you've still
got some fantastic foliage to look at
and my final trick especially for a
tropical style Garden is to use
epiphytes epiphytes are plants that grow
on larger living plant hosts so things
like my tropical bromeliads these plants
are adapted to survive without soil
around the roots they actually use the
roots to attach onto bigger plants now
there are some that are borderline Hardy
in the UK but I use a lot of these as
summer displays and it just adds so much
height in limited space I'm so pleased
that I've used them in this narrow
border that flanks the side of the
Garden Path by utilizing available
vertical space it's really helped give
that Lush jungly feel
I hope this selection of tips that I use
to maximize the growing space in my own
small tropical style Garden has helped
inspire you whether you're growing in a
garden or in a balcony or in a courtyard
this will even apply to house plants not
all plants need to be grown in their own
individual pots you can combine them to
create your own miniature indoor
rainforest
thank you so much for watching and if
you found this content valuable please
hit subscribe it's the easiest way to
support the channel and if you've got
any questions create a free account on
our social network and Forum where there
are gardeners and Growers from around
the world supporting each other and
sharing pictures
thank you and I will see you in the next
one
[Music]